so I'm going to read something that
meets your Road in the first part beyond
an eagle which is a section called
prejudices of philosophers and it's a
really good example of the density of
this book one of the ways of
conceptualizing beyond good and evil and
I think this is true for most great
works of it's true most great works is
that the author of the work collects
unconsciously collects patterns from his
or her interaction with the world
and then gives them initial formulation
and the patterns can be deep and
multi-level and the initial formulation
translates them into not so much ideas
as into the seeds of future ideas and
the more poetically Arthur happens to be
the more the case that his or her
ratings contained within the seeds of
future ideas and were the romantic
philosophers or authors and I think
Nietzsche and Dostoevsky are in some
sense foremost among them are
particularly notable for their ability
to do exactly that now in this
particular paragraph this particular
paragraph not only serves as an example
of that but it also serves as a
self-conscious reflection on that
because Nietzsche is writing a paragraph
here that is full of the seeds of ideas
that will actually bloom and flower to a
great degree in the 20th century but
well he's simultaneously revealing these
those ideas he's also telling you
exactly how he's doing it and how it is
that philosophers do it so it's a it's a
spectacular accomplishment I'm going to
read it
probably phrase by phrase and then take
it apart because it's so dance and
beyond good evil is like that it's each
year when Nietzsche was reading the
unwitting evil
he wasn't very well and because of that
he had to spend a lot of time thinking
and not very much time writing and
because he was also brilliant beyond
comprehension
his ability to distill what he was
thinking into incredibly rich phrases is
I think in some sense it's beyond
parallel I mean often if I'm reading a
book if it has any utility at all market
usually I fold over the top of the page
or sometimes pretty yellow sticky note I
want to do if I find a place where
there's an idea that's worth returning
to that that's that's particularly worth
understanding and you can't do that with
a book like Beyond Good and Evil because
what happens up happening is you have to
mark every sentence and obviously
marking every sentence isn't any better
than not marking any sentences at all so
I guess I also might as well tell you
why it is worth bothering with a book
like this at all because it's a very
difficult book in it it's also the sort
of book that will rattle you up so each
if is is very interested in the problem
of value and the problem of value
fundamentally is not the problem of what
is the world made of or even how does
the world function which are more in
some sense more specifically scientific
questions but how is it that you should
conduct yourself in the world how should
you act and people act towards aims in a
sense because we're active creatures and
we're moving from one point to another
we're moving towards things that we want
and that means that we're guided by our
desires and we're not only guided by
desires insofar as we have individual
desires we're guided by the structure
that consists of how those desires are
related to one another so for example if
you have a room full of people say a
room full of children they're active and
they're each pursuing their individual
desires but at some point they may
choose to organize themselves into a
game and if they organize themselves
into a game what they're doing for all
intents and purposes is producing a
little society little micro society
within that micro society they're
deciding what desires will be currently
expressed and how they'll exist in
relationship to one another and that
means that they can cooperate without
too much conflict and that they can
jointly move towards a joint aim without
and and gather all the benefits that
might be associated with that and that
might be the accomplishment of the aim
whatever it is but it also might be just
the enjoyment that's to be had in the
pursuit of that
activity now people do that socially
because we have to do that in order to
get along with other people because our
desires have to be melded with those of
other people but we also do it
psychologically and those two things
exist in a dance because as I'm
interacting with other people the
demands of the fact that we're
interacting may require each of us to
arrange our desires in a way that's
acceptable to everyone else but at the
same time while we're doing that we're
also observing the process by which
those desires are ordered and then we
internalize that process and use that to
order our own desires
and then so there's a constant mutually
informative dance between the individual
and the group and the culmination of
that is the organization of society and
the simultaneous organization of the
psyche and it's that process that
Nietzsche is talking about in these
paragraphs now you might ask yourself
well what's the utility of articulating
such things and conceptualizing them and
understanding them and the answer in
some ways is straightforward if you
don't want to run afoul of your own
desires you have to organize them
because some of them are short-term and
some of them are medium-term and some of
them are long-term and some of the main
this and some of the main at that and it
isn't necessarily the case that those
desires allow for mutual fulfillment so
for example maybe you're very interested
in pursuing a sexual relationship with
someone but you're also very interested
in having a family and some stability in
your life or maybe you're interested in
pursuing a sexual relationship with a
whole sequence of people but you're also
interested in having a family and
stabilizing your life it's not obvious
that those desires can exist in the same
universe without producing what you
might think about as war and some of
that might be a psychological war
some of its also going to be a war that
actually occurs in existence while
you're fighting through the
contradictory consequences of wanting to
pursue many people and formulate a
stable relationship with one person now
part of the reason that you want to
think about these sorts of things is
because if you think about them and get
your thoughts and your value system
intelligently and coherently and
cogently laid out then when you act out
that value system in the world you're
going to run into less conflict and less
uncertainty and less misery and you're
going to have a higher probability of
getting what it is that you want but
you're also going to have a higher
probability of getting what you want in
a way that allows you to cooperate with
other people without entering into too
much conflict with them and so in some
sense the purpose that you think the
reason that you think are the purpose of
thinking is so that you can sort out how
you're going to move forward in the
world without having to directly run
headlong into all the obstacles that you
might run into if you were doing such a
thing blindly and so then you might ask
yourself well why would you bother
reading philosophy or the philosophy
written by someone who's great and the
answer to that is this that they can
help you think these things through in a
manner that you would not be capable of
doing on your own you know because
Nietzsche minutes it's difficult to
estimate how intelligent Nietzsche was
but I suspect he was perhaps one in a
billion which would put him far beyond
the 99.999% aisle and there's a massive
difference between the ability of people
to think as you move farther and farther
out into the extremes of intelligence
and when you have the writings of
someone who's one in a billion then you
can interact with those writings in the
way that enables you if you'll put the
time into
benefit from the spectacular fact of
that intelligence Nietzsche was a full
professor by the time he was 24 at a
time and now he didn't even have to
write his dissertation they just made
him a full professor at a time where
that was that never happened
so this is what he has to say in the
prejudice is a philosopher such as the
first chapter of the book Beyond Good
and Evil it has gradually become clear
to me what every great philosophy up
till now has consisted of namely the
confession of its originator and the
species of involuntary and unconscious
autobiography well that's a deceptive
that's a deceptively simple sentence
even though it's not a particularly
simple sentence because it it stands on
its head what people generally assume
about the process of thinking you
generally think that when you're
thinking you're thinking about because I
mentioned before the structure of the
objective world Nietzsche is is making
an entirely different point here and
what he's fundamentally doing is
treating the philosopher not as a
rational being but as a living being and
there's a big difference between being a
rational being and being a living being
because if you're a living being your
primary goal is to do whatever it is
that furthers your life and if you're a
rational being then your primary goal is
to do whatever it is that a rational
being might do and you could say that a
living being should first and foremost
be a rational being and in some sense
that's the message of the of the Western
enlightenment but it's by no means
self-evident that that's the case and
it's certainly not something that
Nietzsche Nietzsche doesn't believe that
people are rational beings as certainly
not primarily and more importantly he
isn't exactly convinced that they should
be so so for example one of Beach's most
famous Maxim's is that truth serves life
and that's a very difficult different
idea then the purpose of truth says the
accurate representation of the objective
world those aren't the same thing at all
now you could ask well what does it mean
for truth to serve life and if you
construe truth that way what would truth
look like and you know the mere
statement the truth should serve life
doesn't offer you the answers to those
questions but
but it's the beginning of a different
metaphysics and in some sense of
metaphysics which is say the universe
within which a philosopher might operate
a metaphysics is the initial structure
of presuppositions within which a view
of the world is organized one
presupposition might be human beings are
rational and that we're attempting to
formulate and improve our sense of the
objective world our formulation of the
objective world and another would be
that human beings aren't rational were
irrational and that were motivated to do
is to live whatever that means and that
the purpose of our thinking and our
philosophy should be to facilitate our
living and that's Nietzsche's that's one
of the foundation blocks of Nietzsche's
philosophy so he's a moral philosopher
fundamentally because morality is about
values and values essentially values are
you could say values are what you aim
for but it's more complicated than that
values actually constitute the lens
through which you view the world so it's
partly what you're aiming at but it's
also partly your conception of who you
are now and where you are and it's also
partly your conception of how you're
going to get to where it is that you
want to be and it's also partly the
psychological system that you use to
parse up the world so that it reveals to
you the pathway that you can take to get
to what you want values all of that and
then it's more than that because you
could say that you have our value which
contains all of that but then you can
say that you have a set of values which
is the arrangement of all of that and
then you could say that you have a set
of values that's the arrangement of all
that that you have to arrange with other
people and then you could say that you
have all that and you have to arrange it
with other people and you have to
arrange it across different spans of
time because what you want today and
what you want next week and what you
want next month are not necessarily the
same thing and one does not necessarily
lead into the other so to be a moral
philosopher is to examine how that what
that system is and how it operates and
how it came about now one of the things
that Nietzsche says is it has gradually
become clear to me whatever Greek
philosophy up till now is consisted of
namely the confession of its originator
and a species of involuntary and
unconscious autobiography so his claim
fundamentally is that no matter what the
philosopher thinks he's doing while he's
reading philosophy what he's actually
doing is revealing and articulating his
being and then you might say well where
did that being come from and the answer
to that is well partly it's you could
consider it a biological function
insofar as that we have value structures
that are built into us that are the
process we would say the process of a
very long evolutionary history but
because you're also a cultural phenomena
and because the manner in which you've
arranged your values and your desires
has been conditioned to the last degree
by the process of enculturation that you
are subjected to when you confess in an
autobiographical manner and articulate
that what you're also doing is reading
the entire structure of your culture
it's in you and you might say well where
is it in you and about them and what
does it you mean part of it means is
that you act out a pattern of behavior
and that pattern of behavior is like a a
dance that someone is manifesting to a
symphonic score it's unbelievably
complicated and it has its psychological
elements and some of those are conscious
and some of them aren't some of them are
just implicit and embedded in the way
you act and the way you perceive and
what the philosopher is attempting to do
is to reveal those to himself and to
articulate them so that the entire
structure can be analyzed well so
Nietzsche's first proposition is that
when philosopher is thinking that what
he's doing is not thinking it's
revealing himself in an autobiographical
sense under the guise of rational
thinking and so then it becomes
something more like a story and well any
covers all about in the first
two phrases so that gives you some
example some indication of what this
book is like a species of involuntary
and unconscious autobiography well
that's a more complicated idea too
because you might say well why would
someone be driven in a nun book in
voluntary way in an unconscious way to
describe their autobiography and that's
a very complicated question it might be
that one of the reasons that people
value one another is because we engage
in the process of sharing deeply
autobiographical information you tell me
your story and I tell you my story and
you might say well why do we even bother
with such things and the answer to that
is well if you can tell me about the
pain and tragedy that you've encountered
then that gives me a better way that
gives me a better vision of the dangers
of the world without actually having to
expose myself to those dangers except in
simulation I might feel sorry for you I
might feel bad about your tragic
experiences but I'm not bleeding for
them and then there's always the
possibility that you'll also tell me how
you solved your problem in which case I
can either avoid that problem entirely
or if I do encounter I can solve it
without having to go through maybe it
took you decades to formulate your
solution to that problem and you can
tell me your story and then I have the
information and so that's part of what
human beings are always trading that's
why we talk to each other that's why we
can communicate and so Nietzsche would
say well it's it's involuntary
unconscious involuntary and unconscious
he's alluding to the fact that that
proclivity is so deeply embedded in
people that the desire to to make an
autobiographical recounting that it
serves as the kind of motivation that we
don't question for doing almost
everything that we do so you know I mean
people do such things as attend movies
and plays and they usually do that
happily especially if the movie or the
play is of high quality and the same
thing happens with
we're reading novels they're attracted
to such things they have a built-in
value and it's very rarely the case that
people will ever question why it is that
they're doing such things in fact you
see this quite commonly with students
who are first introduced to the study of
literature the the introduction of the
idea that you should analyze what it is
that you're engaged in when you're
reading actually comes as unwelcome news
to most people who are inclined towards
fiction because they don't want to
interfere with the process of engagement
you know automatic unconscious
engagement with the material by
detaching themselves and having to think
about what they're doing so that's why
it's an onion voluntary and unconscious
it's it's one of the things within which
thought operates rather than one of the
things on which thought operates then he
says the moral or immoral purpose in
which every philosophy has constituted
sorry the moral or immoral purpose in
every philosophy has constituted the
true vital germ out of which the entire
plant has always grown well that's a
hell of a thing to say too because what
Nietzsche is alluding to there in some
sense is that
the philosopher can't help and that
would be in some sense also the person
who is recounting their autobiography
can't help but tell you what they're up
to even though they might not know and
this is something that you know because
you know was at Carl Jung the
psychoanalyst was a great student of
Nietzsche and Jung came to believe that
we all inhabited stories that the
stories were the stories we inhabited
were actually the structures of value
within which we live and that those
stories essentially had an ethic or a
moral and then you you can start
thinking about what the ethics and the
morals might be and you kind of have
some sense of that because there's
there's comedic stories and tragic
stories and there's evil characters and
good characters and so forth those are
our particular characters but part of
the point that Nietzsche is attempting
to make here is that the philosopher is
in fact aiming at something with his
life with all of his actions he might
not even know what it is but partly what
he's doing in his attempt to
philosophize is to articulate that and
reveal it to himself and to other people
so then the question becomes well what
is it that the person is up to and I
would say in some sense that's the
ultimate question and so needs you here
in this paragraph it is also dealing
with the with the ultimate question in
life which might be well - what is your
life aimed and you might say well it's
not aimed at anything it's in I don't
know I don't seem to have any coherent
set of beliefs I don't know what I
believe I don't believe in anything even
but that's not the case because if you
didn't believe in anything you couldn't
see you have to believe in something to
be able to see because you point your
eyes and things and you can't organize
your vision without having a name and so
the very act of interacting with the
world presupposes an ethic and then all
those micro ethics that you contain
within you are organized into some sort
of structure either badly or well and
that structure roughly has a name and
you might know it and you might not but
that doesn't mean it isn't there so so
what other thing that means he is
alluding to is that you believe things
whether or not you think you believe
them in fact believing them and know
you believe them aren't even the same
thing and so that people believe all
sorts of things that they don't know
about and then partly what they're doing
when they're doing philosophy is to try
to figure out what those things are you
know and you can also ask yourself well
where did they come from what they
partly came from you but you you're an
old thing your physical form is three
and a half billion years old and you're
the process of all that all the death
and struggling that went along the
entire course of that three and a half
billion years is you carry that with you
and then on top of that inside you is
the consequence of the entire cultural
history of complex life that's all
inside you too and then on top of that
some of that's articulated more or less
some fits act without dramatized
represented in fiction and that sort of
thing and then some of its articulated
but there's way more at the bottom than
is fully articulated and so god only
knows what you're up to
and then you might say well who cares
well the problem with that is that you
care because first of all that's the
definition of caring and second of all
that determines the way that you'll move
through your life and everything that
happens to you that's good or evil or
good or bad is going to be a consequence
of the manifestation of that ethic in
the world
so now Nietzsche is saying something
else too when he says the moral or
immoral purpose in whichever in the
moral or immoral purpose in every
philosophy has constituted the true
vital germ out of which the entire plant
is always grown he's saying that the
Philosopher's can't help but reveal his
aim in his writings and then he's saying
something else which is that iam might
be malevolent and you know modern people
aren't very comfortable with ideas like
malevolence because malevolence is an
idea that's related to evil and modern
people think of themselves as beyond
good and evil to some degree they don't
believe in the reality of those concepts
and of course in this
Peach's also questioning our at least
our a priori presuppositions about what
good and evil are but that doesn't mean
that he doesn't believe that they don't
exist that doesn't mean that he doesn't
believe that they don't exist yes I
guess that's I guess that's right you
know this is one of the things I've
thought about when I was thinking about
when I thought about how Hitler died now
Hitler died Hitler committed suicide in
a bunker underneath Berlin when Europe
was in flames
and so one conclusion that a psycho
analytically minded historian could
derive from that is that's what he
wanted right and then that opens up an
entire vast nest of snakes because one
of the things that you might ask is well
how is it that someone would desire that
first of all could that even be desired
is that actually something that anyone
could even desire then you might ask
well why is it that someone would desire
that and then the next thing you might
ask is if a human being could desire
that and hit there was a human being
then exactly what does that say about
you and you might say well I could never
desire such a thing but following along
the Train of the argument that we've
been laying out is like what makes you
think you're a reliable judge of what it
is that you're up to so okay so now
we've unpacked three sentences and we'll
continue on with the same paragraph
indeed to understand how the most
abstract metaphysical assertions of a
philosopher have been arrived at it is
always well and wise to first ask
oneself what morality do they or does he
aim at so what the question is what's
the personality well
there's an entire nest of snakes
underneath that sentence that's sequence
of propositions as well
and one of them is well what does it
mean that people are up to something
what does it mean that they're aiming at
something
accordingly I do not believe that an
impulse to knowledge is the father of
philosophy but that another impulse here
as elsewhere has only made use of
knowledge and mistaken knowledge as an
instrument but whoever considers the
fundamental impulses of man with a view
to determining how far they may have
here acted is inspiring them this is
partly where this is going to require
editing it's so complicated to go
through accordingly I do not believe
that an impulse to knowledge is the
father of philosophy but that another
impulse here is elsewhere has only made
use of knowledge and mistaken knowledge
as an instrument all right so let's take
that apart accordingly I do not believe
that an impulse to knowledge is the
father of philosophy so one of the
claims I suppose this would be an
Enlightenment claim is that people do
have a drive to knowledge and the that
drive is in fact what underlies the
production of such things as philosophy
but Nietzsche questions that because
he's trying to bring us back to
consideration of the fact that you can't
separate the Philosopher's mind from the
philosophers
being his first and foremost a living
creature and he's up to something and
the question is what is it that he's up
to and so you can see the earliest
manifestations in a paragraph like this
of what later developed into
deconstructionist thought and that that
was mostly French continental
philosophers who pursued that particular
line of reasoning and it is derived
exactly from this kind of statement by
Nietzsche so for example someone like
Derrida would say it doesn't matter what
the content of the text is what matters
is that the text can be used as a tool
for power and then whether the person
who wrote the text knew it or not that's
what they were doing and they were doing
it in a way to privilege themselves
above other people and that's really I
would say the fundamental
constructionist claim and it's a
powerful claim it's an utterly corrupt
claim but it's a really powerful claim
and it's related directly to the sorts
of things that Nietzsche was referring
to in this paragraph what is it that the
persons truly up to now the problem with
the deconstructionist claim is that it's
an it's an open invitation to cynicism
to thoughtless citizens I can just make
the presupposition that whatever it is
that you're telling me you're you're
telling me merely to dominate regardless
of what it is that you claim to be doing
well the problem with that approach is
that it's predicated on the implicit
assumption that the only value that
people actually have is the value to is
the desire to dominate and of course
that's a purely but that could be the
case and I also think that it's even
reasonable to posit that to some degree
that it is the case but to take that
from a contributing factor and to make
that the highest God because that's
essentially what the deconstructionist
SAR doing those are entirely different
things
and you have to beware of people who
take a single causal element and elevate
it to the stature of single
comprehensive cause you know it's more
reasonable to assume that people are
complex in their motivations and that
many different strands of biological and
cultural motivation are in some sense
primary and then what happens is that
they come together to weave a kind of
tapestry rather than to make the
automatic assumption that you can reduce
the entire set of human motivations to a
single principle like that of power now
you know I would say Nietzsche is also
responsible to some degree for the
deconstructionist claim that its power
because one of his most famous
utterances was that the fundamental
motivating force in life is the will to
power but he wasn't so much because
Nietzsche is a so thinker he wasn't so
much attempting to reduce human
motivation to power he was attempting to
redefine what it was that we
conceptualized as power whereas that as
the deconstructionist certainly you know
all because fundamentally they're
Marxists and they believe that you know
they ensconced themselves within an
economic viewpoint where within a
philosophical viewpoint where economics
is paramount and where all that matters
is power construed as socio economic
domination fundamental you know and
that's in turn is embedded in
metaphysics that's even deeper which is
the metaphysics that presumes that
people are fundamentally materialist and
all of those things are quite and all of
those things are highly questionable
so I'm going to skip ahead a little bit
of the paragraph when Nietzsche talks
about the motivations of you might
consider them people who are working in
the middle ranks of bureaucracies
whether they're scientific or otherwise
so they're in some sense acting as cogs
in a particular machine and so that's
what he's describing hearing says in the
case of scholars or in the case of
really scientific men it may be there
may really be such a thing as an impulse
to knowledge some kind of small
independent clockwork which when well
wound up works away industriously to
that end without the rest of the
scholarly impulses taking any material
part there in the actual interests of
the scholar therefore are generally in
quite another direction it is the family
or in money-making or in politics it is
in fact almost indifferent at what point
of research his little machine is placed
and whether the hopeful young worker
becomes a good philologist someone who
studied it or to the boards a mushroom
specialist or a chemist is not
characterized becoming this by this he's
not characterized by becoming this or
that
Nietzsche's point they're fundamentally
is that even when you do analyze people
who in whom the will to knowledge might
actually be offered even though he
wouldn't be willing to granted the
status of highest motivating power that
even in those people where that will to
knowledge does exist the probability
that that is in turn subordinated to
some other principle that's higher in
the value hierarchy is very very high
and it's hard to tell exactly what that
additional principle might be but he
points out such things as well maybe
they're primarily interested in serving
the interests of their family or they're
primarily interested in making money or
maybe they're primarily interested in
status and maybe they're interested in
status status becomes it because it
makes them more sexually attractive and
that sort of thing so but the question
of what is it that's lurking in the
background is always paramount so
another
detour in this particular paragraph
whoever considers the fundamental
impulses of man with a view to
determining how far they may have here
acted as inspiring gene I or as demons
will find that they have all practiced
philosophy at one time or another
and that each of them would have been
only too glad to look upon itself as the
ultimate end of existence and the
legitimate Lord over all of the other
impulses
that's another like the Beyond Good and
Evil to think of it as a book is a
really foolish framework you know
because this is what a book is when
people think about a book no it's like a
material entity it's it's eight inches
high and six inches wide and two inches
thick and weighs a pound and it's made
out of paper it's between two two covers
you know and that's a materialist that's
the a priori sort of axiomatic view of
the book Nietzsche's Beyond Good and
Evil isn't a book at all it's a series
of bombs and each sentence is a ball and
each sentence blows things up that
people don't even know exists and so one
of the things with this sentence for
example here's how he's conceptualize a
human being so the first thing he talks
about is that the [ __ ] there are
fundamental impulses of human beings
okay so that thing's questions what do
you mean by impulse and what do you mean
by fundamental and both of those are
externally complicated problems so an
impulse you can think of an impulse as a
drive you could think about it as a
biological instinct you could think
about it as an aim or a goal you could
think about it as an act of will like
there's there's endless questions that
hang off that question but we could
start with the idea that we perhaps
can't define it but we are willing to go
with the proposition that people do have
impulses and I think maybe that's
manifest to you more
particularly when you're attempting to
do something voluntarily and something
involuntarily interferes with that you
know so maybe you're sitting down to to
try to get some work done in the work is
not of any particular intrinsic interest
but you regard it as necessary
you know necessary element in some
higher order scheme and so you're
attempting to organize yourself so you
will in fact concentrate on that
particular relatively mundane activity
but what you find when you sit down to
actually engage in that is you can't do
it you have to go do the dishes or you
have to clean under the bed or you have
to have a sexual fantasy or you or
there's some other thing that you could
do this useful but that you would
normally do that you'll go do instead or
that you fall asleep or that you get
hungry or like there's an endless number
let's call them impulses that might
arise to interfere with your conscious
movement forward well exactly what are
those things while nature certainly
conceptualizes the human being has a
place where those things lived and it
does mean live to because it wouldn't
refer to them as deep demons or or
genies without introducing the
metaphorical conception of something
that lives and so hardly what Nietzsche
reveals in those sentences is that he
conceptualized as a human being as the
dwelling place of spirits and some of
them are Genii let's say that's the
group word of genius that's the terribly
powerful thing that exists in the
terribly small compartment right that
you have to call forth and some of them
are demons and demons are things that
have their own autonomous will and the
generally aren't aiming for the good so
then so those are all things need she
just lays out as implicit parts of the
sentence so he activates all those ideas
whether you know it or not in your mind
to the degree that you process the
sentence and those things start to take
on a life of their own those ideas and
so then he adds another dimension of
complexity to that by saying well you're
full of demons and
and genies and they're all doing their
own thing whatever that happens to be
but each of them if left to their own
devices would attempt to remake the
entire world in their form and so I
thought of this from from a narrative
point of view or from a symbolic point
of view in old stories in folk tales and
fairy tales you often have Cyclops there
one night Giants and there's a sexual
connotation to that which is which is
our proposed that the psychoanalysts
would would certainly point out but the
one eye idea is that this thing is
gigantic
who wants one thing and so that's
another way that Nietzsche is
conceptualizing the fundamental
structure of the human psyche
it's a dwelling place full of one-eyed
Giants and they're constantly well one
thing one way of looking at is they're
constantly at war one of them wants to
be the largest one-eyed giant and
dominate everything else and then one of
the things that so Nietzsche takes that
argument further he says not only is
this always happening in human beings
but that if you look at philosophy what
it is is it's a continual revelation of
the attempt of some singular minded
psychic monsters
psychological monster to dominate the
entire psychological structure than ER
for the entire cultural structure
therefore the entire world and then you
can you can see in that the entire
religious structure struggle of mankind
to take this vast polytheistic vision of
reality and to organize it into some
sort of monotheistic and integrated
structure which you could also consider
indistinguishable from them civilizing
the impulse that operates in human
beings to become civilized because on
the one hand it might
a terrible thing that one one-eyed
monster emerges to attempt to dominate
all the others but then on the other
hand there's no difference between that
and organizing something because to
organize something is to bring it all
into a hierarchical structure with some
sort of singular value at the forefront
and then the question might be well what
should that singular value be and then
Nietzsche would that ties it the whole
argument back into the first sentences
that he wrote at the beginning of the
paragraph which is well what is it that
the philosopher is up to what is the
force that he's serving what is the
unifying impulse that's another way of
looking at it if there's a unifying
impulse and he's not only fallen prey to
some internal demon if there's a
unifying impulse to bring all of this
together into some sort of functional
structure what exactly might that look
like for every impulse is imperious and
as such attempts to philosophize that's
part of that sort of Nietzsche's idea of
will to power in in its nascent form
like all of these unconscious entities
that inhabit that human psyche are all
alive and they're trying to live they're
trying to look they're trying to climb
up the dominance hierarchy and dominate
because of course that's partly what
life does because let's say from an
evolutionary perspective and this is
probably more true for males because
there are less effective in their
attempts to replicate the distinction
between
climbing up a dominance hierarchy
whatever that might happen to be and
success is there may be no distinction
at all and then you might say well that
just shows that there's nothing but will
to power but that still doesn't answer
one of the most fundamental questions is
that power in relationship to what
because that's the question
okay so you can shut that ball